Mitch McConnell has been the obstructor in
chief, sort of the real hatchet man for Republican,
and he's been doing a brilliant job of just
getting in the way of stuff we've talked about.
I mean, over the last couple of years he prevented
Merritt Garland from having Supreme Court
confirmation hearings under Barack Obama.
So Donald Trump got himself an extra supreme
court pick thanks to Mitch Mcconnell.
He has been preventing election security bills
from being debated while he takes money from
lobbyists for the two biggest voting machine
companies in the United States.
And he was on Fox News and instead of addressing
any of those obstructive acts, which he should
address, and I would love to hear him pressed
about, he said, Oh, if Puerto Rico and Washington
DC become states, that would be part of the
socialist agenda of the democratically controlled
House of Representatives, statehood for DC
and Puerto Rico would be in some way socialistic
according to Mitch Mcconnell.
Take a listen to this
for the first time in my memory.
I've got agree with Nancy Pelosi.
I am indeed the ground reaper when it comes
to the socialist agenda that they've been
getting up over in the house with overwhelming
democratic support and sending it over to
America and things that would turn us into
a country.
We've never been there on their way to doing
some additional things in addition to the
ones that I've already done the green new
deal a medicare for all.
And by the way, you may have mentioned this
on your show, but they didn't plan a plan
to uh, to make the district of Columbia state
that getting to know Democratic senators,
uh, Puerto Rico state, we give him two more
new democratic senators and as a former supreme
court clerk yourself, you've surely noticed
today plan to expand the Supreme Court.
So this is a full boar socialism on the march
in the house and yeah, as long as I'm the
majority leader of the Senate, none of that
stuff is going anywhere.
None of that stuff he says is going anywhere.
Now understand the complete and total misdirection
that is going on here.
Mitch Mcconnell is sort of good at this, but
of course he's helped along by Fox News by
Fox News, letting him do it.
Mitch Mcconnell obstructed bills meant to
release an unredacted version of the Mueller
report, multiple bills.
In fact, he wouldn't give him the time of
day just dead on arrival to the Senate.
Mitch Mcconnell continues to obstruct every
election security bill meant to protect the
2020 election and future elections from future
interference.
He's doing that now and his campaign is getting
money from lobbyists for the two biggest voting
machine manufacturers in the United States.
And yet he goes on Fox News and says, I control
the discussion in the Senate and no, none
of this socialist stuff is going anywhere
under my watch.
What about election security that you keep
obstructing?
And then of course we have to at least briefly
address that DC and Puerto Rico becoming states
isn't Socialists Socialism of course, defined
as a range of economic and social systems
characterized by social ownership of the means
of production and workers, self management
as well as the political theories and movements
associated with them.
And as you can see by looking at the definition
of socialism that territories and federal
districts becoming states is not socialism.
I'm not a socialist.
But when the right starts calling things socialism,
my ears perk up because there's a very good
chance that those are pretty damn good ideas.
If they are being a sailed as socialism by
uninformed Republicans, Steve King, you might
remember horrible, racist, xenophobic Republican
congressman once said that gay marriage is
socialism to men.
Being able to get married is like the workers
controlling the means of production.
Why?
Well, what are you talking about?
Gay Marriage is social ownership of the means
of production.
This is their move.
If they want to oppose something, they call
it socialist, even if it's not, and in fact,
DC and Puerto Rico having a say in government
matters that affect them is not socialism.
It's representative democracy, which I thought
was the system that we had and it's really
important to note that not all Republicans
or even United on this DC statehood thing,
there are Republicans that are supportive
of DC statehood.
There are probably more Republicans that are
supportive of Puerto Rican statehood rather
than DC statehood, but this is the postmodernism
that they claim to oppose.
They accuse us of having no fixed meanings
for language and concepts and words.
Everything is malleable, nothing has any meaning.
It can all be whatever we want it to be and
then they say, oh, statehood for territories
and federal districts, that's socialism, which
implies words have no meaning.
Nothing means anything.
Anything can be socialism.
If Republicans determined that it's bad, this
guy must be removed as important.
I would say as the removal of Donald Trump
from the White House.
When you think about just the next several
decades and the impact on the justice system
and the courts and so much else, we've got
to remove Mitch Mcconnell.
It's, it's if it's not as important as we're
moving trumpets.
Very, very close.